welcome back everyone who is ready to go
racing
nascar will be here in two weeks and jc
is at the track with waze
for you to get behind the wheel of your
own stock car hey jc
lindsey this is going to be crazy so
here we are nascar racing experience
i'm in the car ready to go todd real
quick what's the safety features we have
dialed in here yeah so you've got a
helmet on you've got a hans device a
fire suit
and a five point seat belt okay and then
once we get on the track
what are we looking at what kind of
track we looking at yeah so this is a
mile and a half
uh d-shaped race track 22 degrees of
banking
and the turns 12 degrees in the front
and back stretch all right we're gonna
fire it up here in a second guys i think
you might lose me at some point the
audio but
lance will keep the video going feel
free to do some play-by-play
he's going to uh the safety harness that
goes up here
oh my gosh car stall be safe drive
safely
here we go guys all right jc
andy's off i don't know how to i don't
know how to commentate racing
i'm not really sure how to do it either
but it's fun it looks fast the car looks
fast
how would we be as being a great network
for nascar
for nascar commentators he's going
around
the track quickly
a little bit quicker now we can't see
him anymore
no but we might soon but i promise you
he's there
he's on the track a riveting live shot
where did he go where did did he drive
to another dimension i don't understand
okay is he gonna come back how long are
we
uh we're just gonna hang on here okay
you guys are horrible
we're we're trying ted we're trying what
are we doing
he's coming around the bend and i don't
know
keep going no that's all i can do too
he's in the league
but he's
you are well done you are the king of
the track
the king of the track all right
yes the king of the track thank you